quando discuto con gli amici di
architettura Di arte viene sempre fuori
il tema l'originalità no hai copiato
qualcuno quello inedito allora
riflettendo Però sulla storia del
costume e anche dell'arte e poi la mia
arte e l'architettura evidentemente
ho pensato una cosa quando noi parliamo
del concetto di identità
nell'antichità avere identità voleva
dire appartenere un gruppo sociale o di
potere Ma anche spesso dotato di codici
molto precisi ancora adesso gli uomini
fanno tutti smoking nelle feste per cui
esistono non arrivo a dire delle divise
Ma certamente delle convenzioni per
esempio nel vestire o nell'agire che
spesso permettono di capire a chi
appartiene una persona per cui in realtà
l'identità aveva a che fare con la
condivisione di costumi spesso molto
pensate al collare bianco del 600
nell'architettura quello che possiamo
chiamare l'architettura classica in
fondo il vestire all'inglese e
l'architettura classica sono due codici
che noi possiamo fare un trattato
possiamo leggere un manuale capire come
si fa questo è preso da un architetto
del diciamo francese delle corde
d'azzardo lui dice per fare un
qualsivoglia progetto è molto semplice
traccio degli assi principali traccio
degli assi secondari metto i muri e poi
le colonne Ma i pezzi dell'ego di questo
architetto Di fatto vengono dalla
classicità e il Pantheon Romano le terme
per cui avevamo una scatola di
costruzione già belle pronta non ci si
poneva un problema di disegnare le parti
ma solo di comporle bene
un qualsiasi concorso del Cinquecento e
questo famoso per la facciata del San
Petronio a Bologna che ancora lì se voi
pensate
rifatta aveva una serie di variazioni
c'era tutto un tema nel Cinquecento
sadattarsi alla Struttura gotica essere
più rinascimentali però di fatto
prendendo tutte le cose un po'
sassomigliano tra di loro
Però qualcosa è successo oggi
identità significa originalità Questa è
una canzone I miei tempi I'm not like
Everybody else dei Kings No sono diverso
dagli altri quante volte sentiamo su
internet per esempio questa affermazione
e direi che Fedez e la Ferragni
con loro bambino non so quanto poi sia
bello mettere in piazza bambino Sono
l'esempio di questa forma identitaria in
questo caso gestita meravigliosamente
due persone molto intelligenti Ma
l'esibizione continua di un
individualità e quello che poi porta
milioni di follower che a loro volta
cerco di imitarlo c'è un caposcuola
originale poi tutti che cercano di
imitare
anche qui potremmo tornare un po'
indietro nel senso che se pensiamo al
concetto di slogan qualcosa di urlato è
una meccanismo che è stranamente comune
alla civiltà commerciale La reclam ma
anche all'avanguardia pensate
all'avanguardia dei primi del secolo
scorso no questo tema del Manifesto di
urlare di dire qualcosa di affermare per
cui questa doppiezza percorre la storia
del Novecento
una volta gli artisti o degli Artigiani
che si mettevano a dipingere bene nel
Novecento nasce un'altra figura Salvador
Dalì che passeggia per Parigi col suo
formichiere e Andy Warhol che lancia
Basquiat e facendo un match di boxe No
in fondo da lì e poi War sono degli
Artisti che fanno delle cose ma sono
anche loro stesse la vita arte
evidentemente esiste tutta una pletor
Sono l'esempio della persona dove il
fuoco non è più sull'opera ma sul
personaggio in quanto tale
Allora noi siamo liberi di esprimerci no
la nostra anzi questa cosa è vista con
un valore però andando in viaggio in
Sicilia
passando di fronte ai templi di
Agrigento vede Oste sculture che qualche
assessore aveva messo a me sembravano
personalmente orribili e specialmente
stonate per cui la città è lo spazio di
tutti nelle altre arti io posso suonare
scrivere un libro fa quello che voglio
ma poi il mio pubblico se lo senti in
cuffia lo legge la camera da letto
quando veniamo all'architettura lo
spazio pubblico di tutti quello che
esprimo io in qualche modo ha percepito
da tutti i grattacieli di Milano lì li
stiamo guardando tutti
per cui è come se fosse nata
un'architettura in inglese
higher to Please vuol dire ansioso di
piacere e c'è una canzone di Leonard
Cohen che si chiama Please don't past me
bike per favore non passarmi davanti
come è un cartello di un cieco no
mendicante ma lui la generalizza
Andy War stesso diceva Ognuno di noi ha
un quarto d'ora per essere famosi questi
architetture che vediamo pubblicate
tutti i giorni sui giornali e costruite
sembrano architetture che cercano di
cogliere in un attimo solo un passante
distratto ma quasi come se avessi una
sola chance di un'audizione di far colpo
di far colpo sugli altri no E
Sembrerebbe che il loro scopo sia per
esempio non essere costruite bene nel
senso tecnico ma fare una buona
impressione No questa continua ricerca
del consenso in questo caso dei
Followers
in certi casi ciò può andar bene quando
veniamo un tema delicato perché si può
andare dietro di 2000 anni il tema del
cos'è la forma della chiesa No è a Bari
c'è quella che la chiamano rifugio di
Mazinga Ufo Robot e questo sistema
ognuno è libero di interpretare in
questo caso un concetto religioso Qui ci
sono dentro anche architetture d'autore
per carità a modo suo in qualche modo
non ci soddisfa tanto quanto
le chiese che abbiamo visto prima no
qualche Tutti capiscono e comprendono e
forse apprezzano quelle e qui è lasciato
a sua volta al gusto individuale
possiamo dibattere quali di questo ci
piace quale che no
nell'ultimo secolo c'era questo tema che
in architettura potremmo chiamare
l'espressionismo strutturale la
sincerità della struttura per cui c'è
come un'alleanza storica tra
lo sfoggio di bravura degli Ingegneri di
fare le strutture molto ardite è l'idea
dell'innalzamento in questo caso verso
il cielo per cui mentre la Porziuncola
di
San Francesco è in fondo un Granaio
dedicato al signore qui la chiesa dice
io vengo direttamente da lassù no come
nei Blues Brothers dice mi manda lui no
c'è qualcosa ti fa dire io non sono di
questo mondo vengo da lassù
questo tema
be different Just Do It Artist quello
che è interessante che
le grandi società produttrici di vestiti
profumi scarpe Ti stan dicendo tu sei
unico tu sei originale Pensa con la tua
testa e in realtà se queste se le cose
che leggiamo su Internet valgono per
tutti noi tutti siamo tutti e come un
paradosso che pochi colgono no come li
assegni different Però è una specie di
omologazione e rivedevo Un comico che
aveva la scritta la sua maglietta sono
anticonformista come tutti gli altri
uno dei miei gruppi preferiti sono i New
pornographer che han fatto un disco che
si chiama mess Romantic romanticismo di
massa Ecco che se una volta nel 900
c'era l'uomo tipo un po' tutti uguali
adesso Lidia stessa che ognuno deve
esprimere qualcosa e vede il Tom
potrebbe essere il simbolo dei Mille
Colori però Esiste un gruppo di
fotografi e di stilisti olandese che ha
fondato questo gruppo si chiama
executives che gira per le città
d'Italia e chiama le persone alle poste
in studio e le fotografa così come le
vedete per cui ci sono accertamenti
almeno 12 CNO Zucchi 12
Ferragni se così via questi sono quei
tipi che spiegano il film La fidanzata
quando escono dal cinema Anteo alcuni
sono presi a Milano poi i titoli sono
bellissimi Pokémon così quelle lì ancora
milanesi vanno in giro per tutta Europa
mi piacciono da pazzi quelli con la
camicia mezza fuori un atto così
spontaneo come lasciare la camicia mezza
fuori apparentemente in maniera
disordinata viene codificato per cui
ognuno di noi cerca di essere originale
ma almeno 12 ne troviamo
però questa
variazione omogeneità in realtà potrebbe
essere presa chi forma positiva Queste
sono foto di edifici residenziali degli
anni diciamo dopoguerra presa a Milano
andando in vespa a insegnare al
Politecnico ho fermato La Vespa gli ho
prese in una abitava pure mia nonna e
ognuno di questa è una cellula Dove
abita una persona avrà un gatto ma tutti
insieme fanno lo sfondo della nostra
città più o meno bella ma forse la
ripetizione a città se pensiamo alla
Parigi a osmann tutta bianca quanto è
bella e anche legata a un codice più o
meno auto imposto per cui ci potrebbe
essere un elemento positivo per far
città bisogna essere simili
Però in realtà io volevo parlare di
un'altra cosa il tema di quello che
potremmo chiamare la ripetizione
differente cioè come nel telefono senza
fili ognuno capisce e ripete in maniera
leggermente differente così queste sono
le coppie Barbare di monete romane dove
c'è la coppia della coppia della coppia
la coppia e ognuno che copia copia solo
quello precedente in realtà si passa da
una figura di una testa di Cesare o di
un carro fino a una cosa astratta che si
dimentica completamente una specie di
meccanismo quasi darvinista che potremmo
applicare
all'evoluzione della specie ma anche
all'evoluzione degli oggetti che man
mano cambiano pensiamo ai cellulari che
usiamo tutti i giorni
l'evoluzione però non è lineare Questo è
uno schizzo originale di Darwin e
vediamo per esempio l'uomo di
neanderthals è praticamente estinto e
anche altri rami degli uomini si sono
estinti Non è vero che l'evoluzione va
tutto dritto per cui il fallimento è
sostanziale alla vincita di un ramo
progettando qualche tempo fa ho preso le
foto dei modellini di studio di un
concorso avanzato per legna a Milano e
li ho messi in sequenza Quasi come
fossero le fasi evolutive di un insetto
fino a quello che vince
alcuni studiosi si sono occupati a
questione c'è Richard Docks che da Town
è un biologo che dice come il gene vuole
clonarsi tante volte così Memi questa
parola Meme voi la conoscete
lo vede come unità di informazione che
vuole trasmettersi la differenza è che
trasmette anche le variazioni lungo il
suo corso e anche da Asperger che ha
scritto un bellissimo libro si chiama
una teoria della cultura un approccio
naturalistico parla proprio delle
epidemiologie delle idee le idee pensata
delle parole come inclusivo resiliente
quanto che sono parole giustissime o
sostenibilità se noi andassimo a vedere
quante volte sono pronunciato a un certo
momento a un certo punto c'è una specie
di Fallout radioattivo dal tuo giorno al
ristorante parlavamo della resilienza
della melanzana
e ci sono alcuni studiosi in questo caso
kublier che analizza la storia dell'arte
Come la continua ripetizione e diciamo
innovazione e ripetizione come
meccanismi motori dell'arte tanti anni
fa mi è interessato perché è proprio il
titolo di questa sera avevo fatto un
installazione a una biennale si chiamava
Command Ground e avevo esposti insieme
insetti questi sono dei mattarelli da
Pane del Rajasthan sommergibili la forma
degli aerei sommergibili potremmo
ordinarla come insetti piccoli monumenti
e foto in una specie di grande
installazione che simulava quasi la
complessità della città e più o meno gli
stessi anni mi ero messo ossessivamente
a ridisegnare i cortili Milanese Ho
fatto questo libro dove anche in fondo è
una specie di tavola sinottica di molti
cortili di Milano dove potremmo dire che
la città potrebbe essere vista in questo
senso
più avanti nel tempo mi è capitato di
lavorare alla Alfa Romeo fratello vicino
a piazzale Accursio fatto queste case di
edilizia sociale con questo motivo del
cotto e anche di pietra bianca e poi mi
sono reso conto dopo che Milano non ha
solo romanico vero ma tutto la forma di
romanico fino ottocentesche che una
specie di architettura milanese però
davvero me ne sono reso conto quasi ex
post e allora mi è venuto in mente
questa frase di Paul Valery mio amato
che dice ciò che non assomiglia niente
Non esiste
nel frattempo delle architette straniere
mi han chiesto di fare una cosa su
caccia Dominioni un maestro milanese
aveva fatto un'installazione sempre in
biennale mostrando una sua casa ma poi
mi sono reso conto che anche copiato
caccia Dominioni Questo sono io il
babycino con caccia Dominioni del 63 e
quello al suo centesimo compleanno ho
avuto un rapporto anche familiare ma poi
mi sono reso conto anche più
inconsciamente di aver copiato
coronamento a casa lavezzari Questo è
uno schizzo autografo di caccia
Dominioni vecchio che m'ha chiamato mi
ha detto mi ha fatto una correzione
sulle mie case per cui Ritornando al mio
caro Paul Valery è interessante niente
più originale che nutrirsi gli altri ma
bisogna digerirli il leone è fatto di
montone assimilato ma è sempre piaciuto
molto
ancora tanti anni fa ho fatto un'area
dismessa a Venezia è difficile per un
architetto lavorare a Venezia molto
complessa un insieme di ristrutturazioni
edifici industriali esistenti edifici
nuovi
erano un'area industriale come era
dietro al Palladio ma uno di questi
edifici questo qui che aveva una sigla
si chiama l'edificio D ha colpito
l'immaginazione qui prendendomi in giro
detto Come si fa una casa a Venezia
prendere il foglio di carta macellaio
mette sul giradischi tizio Fabrizio
Andrè tutti morimmo a stento tra il
primo amore piangere un po' disegnare le
finestre dove sono cadute le lacrime o
plate Ecco qua Però il tentativo era
anche quello di fare un edificio
contemporaneo che però non chiudendo un
po' gli occhi non fosse così diverso non
capisco ancora se ho fatto Mondrian o
pittoresco quello che è interessante che
ero un anno fa a Vienna e mi han detto
dezuki Windows riferendosi a
quell'edificio lì come dico come le
tranquillo Sì quella che tu hai fatto a
Venezia questo motivo si è diffuso in
tutta Europa e l'altro giorno passando
al Politecnico entrando Qualche
professore del primo anno ha dato la
casa da fare come esercizio di primina
di studenti e di questa casa è stata
riprodotta da carte da gioco i siti
Internet da pittori quello c'è l'alino
che la porta ha avuto una specie di
veramente di vita memetica e addirittura
un caricaturista me l'ha rappresentato i
definendo me come l'uomo della delle
finestre bianche ma nessuno sa che io ho
copiato queste finestre da un edificio
di Gabetti e Isola che sono dei maestri
piemontesi del 75 sono considerato
l'autore di un motivo che ho copiato da
un altro per cui
venendomi in aiuto con Douglas tadder
che è un grandissimo cibernetico e
diciamo che la variazione del tema come
la croce della creatività
il nodo può portare un concetto
dell'architetto come dj Forse una volta
con compositore Questo sono io che
faccio il dj e questo la mia idola
Natalie merchant che mi è venuta a
trovare in studio e ho scoperto che sta
facendo delle canzoni su un libro di
Lina schwarts ho trovato al mio bambino
gliel'ho regalato per cui oggi forse
montare può essere una forma di
creatività Vi ringrazio molto della
vostra attenzione
[Applauso]